now if the biden transition does happen
if biden does become president
boy oh boy are we in for it joe biden
has announced from the
vaunted office of the president-elect
that he has
given himself he announced that he's
going to put john kerry
the failed secretary of state into a new
position in his administration he will
make him
the climate czar the climate czar i
didn't know there was a climate czar i
guess there isn't one
but now there will be i suppose john
kerry will be in charge of
manipulating science to make all of our
political decisions for us
outside of the authentic realm of
politics
what this tells me what this signals to
me this one appointment of john kerry
is that the biden administration if it
occurs
will be the coronavirus lockdown on
steroids
it will be an administration of
coronavirus lockdowns not just
not specifically with regard to
coronavirus or the lockdown but broadly
to the idea
that we are going to have our politics
dictated to us by
egghead idiots in white lab coats who
are then interpreted by politicians
who want to pretend that they're not
being politicians
and the the rules that come out of the
biden administration are going to
all have the sheen and patina of science
on it
this is something the left has been
doing for now about 150 years
they say no our our political
preferences they're not they're not
politics
it's science we have discovered mark
said this we've discovered the science
of history
the science of politics it's not up for
debate how dare you disagree we know the
science of it and that's what we're
going to get we're going to get new
government offices
that pretend to be non-political purely
scientific and they are going to
exert probably greater influence on our
politics than anything else
in our government john kerry and so if
we're going to have these new scientific
offices that we can't
disagree with that are not open to
debate do we think john kerry is the
right guy for this job
some people forget this john kerry has
been wrong about
everything his whole life i don't think
he's ever been right about a single
thing
ever once he's been wrong since he got
back from vietnam
he's been wrong since he was in the
senate he was certainly wrong as
secretary of state do you remember
when john kerry was secretary of state
he's coming into this role he's speaking
at the brookings institution
he comes in and he says that
there is absolutely no way that you're
going to have
peace between israel and arab nations if
you don't deal
first with the palestinian problem now
you'll recall president trump
took a different approach to israel and
the arab world than his predecessors
in obama in bush in clinton
in the other bush in all these
administrations he trump took a
different approach
he said we're not going to deal with the
palestinian problem first we're just
going to deal with israel and the arab
states
john kerry said that was a complete
disaster there's no way that could ever
possibly work take a listen
to secretary of state thurston howell
iii there will be no separate
peace between israel and the arab world
i want to make that very clear to all of
you i've heard
several prominent politicians in israel
sometimes saying
well the arab world is in a different
place now we just have to reach out to
them and
we can work some things with the arab
world and we'll deal with the
palestinians no
no no and no
i can tell you that reaffirmed even in
the last week as i have talked to
leaders of the arab community
there will be no advance and separate
peace with the arab world
without the palestinian process and
palestinian peace
everybody needs to understand that that
is a
hard reality that's a hard reality
that was completely disproven over the
past four years
100 shredded over the past four years
donald trump has completely ignored the
palestinian problem
he's just dealt with israel's neighbors
and israel itself
and israel has signed record peace deals
with countless arab neighbors
israel bibi netanyahu leader of israel
just
headed over and met with the crown
prince of saudi arabia historic
hasn't happened before trump completely
right kerry completely wrong and carrie
might be
completely infrequently wrong but he's
never in doubt he's always so sure
he has that wasp-ish drawl i promise you
lovey lovey i swear to you as i sit here
sipping my pims cup
israel will never have peace in the
middle east
if we do not deal with palestine
thank you lovey and it turned out that
was completely wrong now what sort of
wrong-headed policies will john kerry
pursue as the climate czar
john kerry he wasn't just wrong about
the palestinian issue in israel by the
way
he was wrong about moving the embassy
you know it was a
u.s policy for decades that the u.s
embassy in israel should be in jerusalem
in reality it was in tel aviv because
americans were too afraid
to put the embassy where they thought it
would irritate
the palestinian arabs well so donald
trump
makes the same promises as everybody
says i guess i'm supposed to put the
embassy in jerusalem okay it sounds good
then he does it i was talking to senator
cruz on our podcast verdict
and apparently when the when the state
department
came in they presented the the arguments
for
for and against moving the embassy in
israel to jerusalem
you had arguments uh for moving it to
jerusalem
zero arguments against moving it to
jerusalem a whole long list
trump does it anyway turns out great and
then a lot of other countries follow
suit and they name a town in israel
after donald trump
who the left still calls an anti-semite
apparently the least successful
anti-semite
in human history john kerry insisted
if you move that embassy you are going
to have
an explosion kerry is also concerned
about the middle east where he spent
nine months trying to secure peace
between the israelis and palestinians
he said the president-elect's campaign
pledged to move the u.s embassy to the
disputed city of jerusalem would
inflame the arab world you'd have an
explosion
an absolute explosion in the region
an absolute explosion actually you had
peace you had record peace
as i mentioned just a little bit earlier
on sunday israeli prime minister bibi
netanyahu
met with saudi crown prince mohammed bin
salman
in saudi arabia this is the first
publicly acknowledged meeting
between a prime minister of the israeli
government
and high level officials of the saudi
arabian government
ever ever shocking record piece
if you had told even me four years ago
that donald trump would bring peace to
the middle east
and i voted for trump i supported trump
i i would have laughed
not because i don't think trump you know
is a talented guy just because
i thought it was an intractable problem
that both parties had tried for a long
time to solve well the reason that both
parties couldn't solve it is because
both parties had exactly the same
approach
and trump had a different approach and
the trump approach worked
and now i do fear if trump is ushered
off the stage
i fear that we're going to return to
some kind of uniparty consensus
this same failed consensus among squishy
republicans and liberal democrats
that we've had for decades in this
country
i do like by the way that what president
trump's doing is
sort of hedging his bets here taking the
legal fight to the courts
still claiming that the election was
fraudulent and that he'll he will
prevail in the end
but also figuring out
how to get enough um enough of his
preferred deals in place before he
leaves
that joe biden can't screw it up too
much i think a lot of what this meeting
was about as well
is that both israel and saudi arabia
fear a renewed iran nuclear deal
if joe biden becomes president and so
they want to get their affairs in order
before that can possibly happen in any
event great news for peace
in the middle east if you enjoyed that
break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
you never miss another video